hello how are you greeting us this al and
jaramillo with your brief informative for
today tuesday june 8 the mother of the boy
found dead near mount in
springs was arrested in denver colorado
this morning she is identified by the
authorities as
35 year old samantha moreno rodríguez  and is accused of
killing and abandoning her 7-year-old son on
Friday, May 28 in a bush
along state route 160
authorities will hold a
press conference in the afternoon to reveal the
latest details about this case
more clinics  vaccination against cob
and they open in the schools of the valley this
week today tomorrow at the high school of el
dorado palo verde spring baby and west ham
and they will offer the fire vaccine for all
those over 12 years of age they will open from
three thirty to five thirty  In the afternoon
the second dose will be available in
the same places after waiting a period
of three weeks.
Today the conventions return after more
than a year of closure due to the pandemic
world congress will be the first to
recover the economy and attract thousands
of tourists to our city this week
nearly 1500 companies will show their
equipment inside the
las vegas convention center
now we pass with your
weather forecast a sunny day with
temperatures near  at 94 degrees the
same winds up to 30 miles per
hour have a good day I am I went out my face
and this was your brief informative for
Disney in Spanish
[Music]